welcome to this video for the round
eight game of the candidates tournament
between Peter Svidler and saggy coyoacán
he was starting the second turn of the
tournament and it starts with all the
Russian games Russians against Russians
the first couple of rounds just down to
make sure that there is no pure Russian
matchup in the last round okay I'm
swidler Kuryakin spitless on fifty
percent and still retains some chances
to to do something in the tournament
what kaioken is on minus two and
basically out of it he has lost two
games one no game and it's really not
looking too great so um let's see how
this game went below Knight f3 yeah he's
really varying things he hadn't played
on e4 earlier he has played see form and
now 93 and g3 interesting choice just um
let's say just playing chess not going
for any deep theoretical preparation
yeah kayaking had played the Berlin
before so Knight f3 and g3 is sort of an
anti Berlin opening okay we see that
kayaking is playing in a very classical
fashion against this Kings via cheto um
he's ready to enter a kettle on for
example if white now goes for see form
castles deform we enter mainline Catalan
which would actually be my choice in
this position I am play this myself as
why this early fianchetto and normally I
go for C for him but this Villa plays d3
interesting going for Kings Indian
attack and after C 5 which is a very
normal reply he came up with a very
interesting move that I actually never
saw before him and
and had a look in the database there's
only one example for the smooth he's
playing an e for him quite surprising
just a form at first it looks like it
just blunders upon but it seems that
things are not so clear at all and this
is quite a quite an interesting concept
and let's check what happens if black
takes of course kayaking didn't take he
played a 96 but let's see what happens
here why just recaptures and here you
can debate um how should black take the
pawn should you lure the rook to d1 or
should you allow y to take and transfer
this Bishop to d8 let's just find human
sake look at this position with the bond
graph yeah I think white retain some
quite interesting play here with 95
that's the idea the night now here is
the tact and it's a bit awkward how to
play now maybe 96 s right and then night
a 3 can be an idea intending to get to
see for this Bishop is just an amazingly
good piece on g2 it seems that this is
pretty decent compensation I mean
Houdini for example if you give it to
the engine it gives e4s just a normal
move with 00 something it's quite
remarkable but it only has been played
very rarely between human players just
one game I found and it is really an
important nuance that you can play you
for without an ID bd2 now BTW to is not
overwhelmingly popular move here but
then i'll show you what's the difference
96 and now Queenie to this is an
interesting point black plays just the
normal moves and now White has the move
see forest at his disposal and this is a
huge difference to the situation with
the night on d to hear white can put the
pawn on c4 and if black no should
side to take then you actually have c3
for your nights a much better square
obviously then d too yeah this set up
with c4 is a very interesting one in the
Kings Indian attack and as it some
somehow hampers blacks counter play on
the queenside in the normal Kings Indian
attack with without this they're very
very often you get this type of position
this is actually rather stupid move
c'mon let's do that g5 is a possibility
but i just want to show you the the
general setup something like that and
black just advances on the queenside at
the fastest possible speed with the c-4
move however inserted this takes lots of
time you need to prepare be five year
and yeah maybe white even can play
Knight c3 later to put more pressure on
d5 a very interesting setup and this is
very interesting in relation to this
afore move as it seems to be possible to
play like that even from the Kings
Indian attack move although it's 93 and
g3 normally this position here with c4
only arises from one a form one is six
the French defense or from the Soviets
with an earlier six so an interesting
move or the wrinkle for people who like
the flank openings this can be an
interesting device thats villa has some
as palladium okay um default default
played by kayak and which really
surprised me this move has a very dodgy
reputation because it opens up the dead
long diagonal and it's not really in any
way helpful to black but kayaking has a
very interesting idea connected to the
move and in fact it's quite interesting
let's see h4 and King edge a this is the
the interesting idea in fact the next
move is the the real point of it King
edge 8 has a very concrete idea and
we'll see now after Bishop f4 which is
very normal kayaking played the move f5
and this is the point of King age eight
because if white now would can show on
f6 black has the very strong reply g
takes f6 they are simply because Queenie
six which would have been a check the
King would have been on g8 is just
really awful because of that move simply
Queen D 593 and black is almost winning
yeah maybe is even winning here that
sets too much really terrible position
yeah white cannot grab only six that's
impossible and if you cannot grab only
six then they capture is completely out
of it because II five is coming and
black has a big Center and why it has no
compensation whatsoever for that so you
cannot take and this means black has
accomplished to play a 5 which in itself
is not so spectacular but it's really it
really makes this position playable if
black is not able to do something like
that he will very much quite often will
be run over on the Kings side if you
place slow moves like that for example
you very often get hit by this kind of
the text and it's super dangerous really
but this is a good idea it control it's
those important squares and makes King
sites attack much much much harder to
play okay Naji five baths Villa this is
the the normal move I guess intending
Queen to h5 it forces I'd like to
capture Dwight recaptured yeah and here
we see a very important moment of the
game the kayaking plays the move Queen
season and here we can see a difference
maybe between an absolute world class
player and just a just a strong
Grandmaster I found again from the early
80s my black um player called Gregorian
Gregorian um yeah there are many
Grigoryants how to tell which one and
he's got 2,450 low rating in 1980s was
very high when even today it's a
decelerating but very decent player
and this guy played a 5 in a game
against Guzman later Grandmaster and
this is in fact a huge mistake because
right now can capture on c6 retakes and
g6 and this is exceptionally strong why
it is almost winning in this position
because the Queen side is completely
seared now there's while skewed at the
wrong word is frozen black hasn't got
any counter play he's got a dead bishop
on c8 this Bishop is completely out of
the game and after this white will get
an almost decisive attack on the king
this is really a winning position you
give it to a computer it's on plus two
wind and it's only rising from that it's
it's it's just dead and then so it can
happen very easily in this position to
get to a hopeless situation a5 is just
terrible really but try a cane is
preventing that he plays Quincy seven so
that if whites could capture now it can
really take with the Queen and even be
ready for counter play another
interesting move was 97 but ok but this
Queen mu vs is perfectly ok it also
increases the pressure only five scores
ya know Svidler plays it interesting it
didn't need to do that but I think it's
an interesting movie played g6
sacrificing a pawn yeah um black needs
to take it there is no no choice it's
something like that it's just so
inviting for later sacrifice that you
are you really shouldn't play that so
the capture is so it's right 92 and King
g8 yeah this is probably necessary at
some point getting out of the age file
yeah I can't black take on e5 yeah this
is not possible very easily and after
this there is this pin so black cannot
take and yeah King King GA this
mentioned was played and this is just a
good prophylactic move that you need to
do anyway 93 heading to this
Square and black gets into defensive
mode covering the important age 7 square
yeah if whiten I would have given really
lots of time he would just like double
triple on the H file and deliver
checkmate but it's not that easy it's
not not really impossible to get them
really quickly and black always has this
possibility to play the night over to
have seven to exchange this attacking
piece on g5 and there are many ways that
right can can try now to increase the
attack what should I did is that I think
okay played g4 not the only move but it
was it was okay 98 in King age to this
versus idea I wanted to get the King
even in some lines to worm you can get
sometimes the king here or you can now
use the g file as well yeah Bishop d7
plate and here we captured on g5 yeah
this is I guess okay but it needs to be
followed up correctly we see that after
the recapture by the upon which is very
logical black has all pieces geared
towards this locating square check yeah
I got at this plate Bishop c6 Queen f3 a
drupe da tour this is really I guess
quite quite logical and look so looks
like a good play rook e1 and queen d 7
now intensifying the pressure on d5 yeah
and I think now in fact um here this
position sula makes a mistake I believe
at least he takes on e6 with the bishop
and after that I think black is somewhat
better
he could also have taken with the night
if i'm not mistaken night takes and here
the interesting point is that white can
still take here it's not necessary now
to capture on c 606 you can take on g6
and as as it is so often there's a
technical justification the only
critical move nurse of course now the
capture and what's now exactly White has
a strong new phase got Queen to h5 and
this is the point that you needed to see
beforehand now night f4 even losers chat
with this capture that's a quite easy
root g1s is deadly after that so you
cannot really a capture black must play
a defensive move here something like
yeah look on the seventh makes a makes
lots of sense um what was my line let's
meet Rock d7 and yeah here white is more
than one possibility can go Bishop to h6
and if you want you can also play this
smooth intending mate and attacking the
rook the the funny thing is that after
Luke age six black can play the the cute
movie a Quincy to check King takes check
check check until here black preserves
an extra pole but white has some I think
by far enough activity activity two to
be okay in this position just for
example line like that rook h6 King g7
rookie to h 17 and f4
why does not not ever going to lose this
position is just far too active I'm not
sure even if I would maybe even prefer
to be YTM probably it's a draw but
Dwight has no problems whatsoever it's
just a simple line there are many there
are ways to deviate from that but I
think this was better to to break
through here on on g6 maybe he misjudged
some some position here I don't know or
maybe he thought the draw is not enough
but also possible that you wanted to try
to to win by at all costs understandable
I mean you need to win games and this
tournament in sweida has one already two
games he also lost two played very
entertaining chess but okay I think what
he's doing is not really yeah I think
it's pretty clear quickly that you
cannot play for win with that and
therefore the other line i think was
really better takes Queen g3 the Queen
was attacked in our group c 8 which is a
pretty good move rook c8 good
prophylactic move that just goes out of
possible a text by the bishop popping up
on g5 ya know night h3 play best builder
taking here on g6 and Queen to f7 yeah
and it's already I think pretty clear
that white will not get a decisive
attack here this is just these pieces
are just too strong in blockading and
black also relatively quickly can always
secure as king um yeah what what are
possible moves here um yeah Queen g6
yeah this is going to end up good I mean
look at this rook if you retreat playing
rock age 8 and why does terribly tie
down here this even if you look at this
mm this yeah like black simply wins you
cannot take on g6 and yeah what what
actually are you doing here I thinks
Willis movers correctly played night
chief non sorry he played Queen year and
queen here he could have played Nagi
fraud this is what I was getting at ow
I'm reading my notes wrong this is what
I thought you should do simply
exchanging off stuff and now something
like that it's a position with opposite
khalid bishops and dwelt okay still all
the heavy pieces on the board but if
white really triples on the G file i I
really don't see black winning this and
anyway um yeah maybe also you can look
here look here Queen here to try queen
age seven i mean this this must be
enough play to draw the game i'm pretty
sure um you already played Queen to h4
and this actually allows something and
this this year the bishop is coming here
and can actually go over to g4 h5 which
is a somewhat awkward looking position
but still I believe that having g6
protected safely as something and well
that's what the bishop is going to do no
Luke g3 and here okay I can decided to
play Queenie seven which is very safe
move from the computer actually just
wants to play Queen d7 and gives black
an almost winning advantage which is
surprising it basically claims that no
black puts the bishop on h5 this keeps
the King side completely secured and
then it wants to start opening things on
the queenside maybe that's true i mean
the computer is
giving this a very high evaluation lot
more than a porn for blankets it's
possible why tests really no attack here
and this is a big difference to the
position with the other with the earlier
95 as I suggested as in this position
with the bishop on c6 there's always g6
that you can attack while here g6 is
protected by this Bishop on age 5 yeah
maybe maybe black is really so much
better yet so it's possible yeah 127
what's the move plate and they both
didn't have so much time Queen trade at
95 now we come to the mentioned endgame
wear black enjoys an extra porn okay
it's not the greatest porn ever but it's
a pond and it's clearer for black what
he wants to do we want to at the right
point maybe play b5 and still it's upon
and we'll see that in fact in the end
this is relevant that there are two G
pawns okay f3 bishop age 5 p-3 or this
is a very normal looking and they both
died well didn't have much time Bishop
f4 I don't think that there's much to
improve here f4 however this is a move
that you need to look at is not so good
because rook a six now you cannot cover
with rookie to also cover the squared
year whites would need to weaken himself
or something negative or pretty terrible
so not f4 of course we should f-4s
better yeah and couple of moves later we
come to the 40th move cockiness
obviously trying to play b5 at some
stage and sweet I needed to make move
for team and he played Bishop g5 and
probably this is not a very precise move
but ok now you're they have little time
they may need to make a move
I'm not sure about the clock terms I
think they both had less less on the
clock than the clock here do show um I
mean by far I think I only still had a
couple of seconds at the end I saw that
on video okay um Bishop g5 ysis probably
not so great yeah ki can now very
quickly played the best f4 and I think
this is a very good practical decision
it just gives black additional options
with with the check the interesting
point is of course that all white needs
to take with the bishop take with the
king check
check your just blundering okay and now
look a fade so black has given up a pawn
for the moment but he has installed this
very nice pressure on a three so white
has a bit of a hard time now to move
pieces you cannot move the bishop as
this just gives up f3 you also cannot
move the king and yeah how do you
actually get your pieces to to some
harmony here an interesting try but I
think swindler does does a decent job
here at her she plays rook f2 covering
their three pawn rook air-five and now
he immediately abandoned the e5 pawn
simply to to get this this passive
position coordinated um I don't really
think that this can be really bad the
computer i don't like doesn't like it
but i think this is a very
understandable move and i still think
white has very decent chances to draw
this you know this seems fairly normal
but instead of Bishop f4 I actually have
a suggestion and what about the idea to
play a 3 in this position just look at
this position from a structural point of
view um white is white is some covering
on f3 we had this weakness is covered
and black cannot at the moment enter
with the rook this is covered this is
kevin is discovered so you have somewhat
of a fortress yeah it's not yeah not in
not a fort not an impeccable fortress
but black needs some time to get
coordination going for example you
cannot easily play g5s suspicious
hanging so you need some time to
coordinate and in the meantime why does
going to play a 3 and b four and he is
attacking those pawns um let's say black
plays look f6 yeah the sir
I think it's a pretty pretty decent move
I'm going before and my idea is to
capture and then attack the d4 pawn
possibly even with Luke age 4 so I think
black needs to play be six year and then
let's say Bishop between yeah and I'm
aware that of course black is still
pressing but I think why does made some
progress the Queen side is not so easily
attackable and maybe under the right
circumstances white can get counter play
against those bonds that are all on dark
squares of course this d three Pawn
might also be attacked at some stage if
you imagine a position with g5g g six
but now this still needs to be done and
I think this is a pretty decent
defensive tribe black can also try this
move but again i'm playing before the
point is that after all this there is
Luke age form and if what gets the d4
pawn it's really it's really completely
ok for him he simply breaks the space
disadvantage and this should be totally
fine black can try a five if you if you
want to look at an alternative and after
that yeah I have the troika and play b5
not sure but about that but yeah maybe I
can even do that and just claim that
this is ok because I can always attack
those those pawns why this verse clearly
but i think you have these insurances to
hold it yes let up late Bishop f4 he
didn't touch anything on the queenside
Bishop rook f5 and Bishop to be eight
and I'm not sure this is a good idea but
it's it's a bit tricky to analyze this
end game I tried but it's very hard to
to get to get to an talkin to a
conclusion there are some things that I
can say I'm pretty definitely about it
but at some point I'm not not sure about
the definitive evaluation cookie 6 plate
here yeah okay black wants to to enter
here rook h4 going for a possible rook
trade ya note that if you return there's
this move which is very uncomfortable
yahoo gauge for andrew p3 form a six
yeah and I think now the next move um
thats well as playing um is I think
should lose really um I'm not one
hundred percent sure if you can really
still save himself but he played Bishop
d6 I guess maybe Bishop a7s a bit tough
of it this definitely should lose but
kayaking is not playing the most precise
continuation he took here kini six I
think it's winning relatively quickly
even um what is white smooth now i don't
i don't really see anything anything
great if you consider that okay the
bishop is just detect where it is where
should it go if you play at the bishop
somewhere where you don't attack
anything like that okay here i can even
attack you but let's say all the way to
be eight then yeah i can even push b5
here or after that you can just cover
with b6 and continue with g5 I think
this something like that for example
just leads to a position which is quite
comparable to the game but i'm going to
take here without losing anything in the
in the center I think it's just a bit
more precise if you look at the game
yeah we see that he gave up on the c5
porn check to get to this position and
here I'm not sure
like us winning I mean maybe is but I am
I wouldn't be one hundred percent sure
about that this all seems quite quite
logical to me white gets the king over
check no King e5 yeah around here we can
yeah well let's say around here it's
very tough to decide which type of
endgame both sides should aim for
especially rook takes f3 as a question
each move is this opposite colored
bishops end game winning or not this is
the important important question to
address on in fact if we look at this
yakini King e5 rook g2 King f4 we came
to this position and here here swidler
played rook to e8 and the question is at
least in my book what about look you
want if you stay on the first rank to
just defend them yeah in a way passively
is it possible for black to win this um
yeah I'm not sure really um it's not so
much at the moment about the two pawns
that extra porn but this advanced pawn
which is supported by the King on if you
look at let's say g4 bisciotti five
check king back and Bishop g3 hmm yeah
um
I'm not so sure if this is winning maybe
it is it looks very good for black but
it seems like a relatively tough defense
and there are also other possibilities
for example if we look at this just for
argument's sake this is not completely
forced and just trying to illustrate
some ideas not tending to to enter check
as mentioned this is not for us I'm just
trying to check to look at this end game
what happens if we actually get to get
this trade I'm not one hundred percent
sure but I think this is a draw as weird
as it sounds but I don't see how black
is going to to promote the Jeep on with
with this King hear this I think King
and Bishop should be able to stop the
Jeep on from just queening and if you
can manage that then you will draw
because well what'swhat's blacks
possible plan then he can switch the
King over to the to the Queen side but
this will be a very easy draw I can I
can show you that for for instance how
can white can take on yourself but
that's not the point really let's just
look at the general idea if black runs
over then why does going to with this
king alone and stop the g pawns and he
can just put something like that on the
board yeah and this is just completely
dead the Queen side is completely
blocked and I'm just staying forever
with my king it's a it's a completely
completely dead wrong and yeah there are
some some drawing chances here mostly
connected with the route trade um
in the game let's look at the game we
are here until you went to eight yeah
and I'm not sure that after that it is
still possible to save because now the
rook is not helping in defense on the
first rank as passive as it looks and
chat after this Bishop f5 on the G pond
will definitely start to run sweedler
was basing his defense on one specific
ID i played roop g8 g6 and Roop g7 you
know and this is an understandable idea
of course as at first sight you might
think okay I'm going to sorry I'm going
to trade rooks now this is nice in fact
if black now trades we will get to an
end game which is very similar to the
one actual before this is in fact i
still believe a draw it's quite the same
even with this some at first you think
okay blacks king is so active but
there's this move and white will
definitely still be able to go over to
stop the Jeep on but look at this
position is this the only move if you
want you can now try to do a calculation
exercise what else could like do in this
position
obviously you're not going to calculate
it in five seconds but just for its it's
very very tough to to even try to
calculate what kayaking know did and
amazingly did I mean very great great
effort but what you need to think about
and definitely should think about is to
take on deform and this is what kayak
ended after 15 minutes of calculation
and this move indeed wins by force it's
just a flat-out win quite amazing takes
and now be 6 the very important point
that white cannot immediately get to the
pawn and take it yeah and the G porn
here is just too strong it's really it's
just like that black black is going to
promote the Jeep on and what's below now
is playing is the absolute toughest
defense you played kings III which
actually threatens king d to ya to go
over and stop the porn with the king
black must play King III rugby 7 yeah
and now it's a it's a matter of really
each move counts g4 rook takes g3 and
the rookies of course returning must do
something about the pawn and now the
second G pawn is coming yeah necessary
now White has got some ponds and its own
yeah and it's still a race and as I
noted there is a relevance to the second
Jeep on look at the G porn it's now the
the winner at the end isn't why going to
promote as well yeah is check out like
is the first to check and it's simply
it's a fast win now white cannot go here
you simply react when the Queen so you
must go here
chand after Queen III check here swidler
resigned or not I didn't sorry he played
kings ii foster which is the only move
of course if you go here the 36 champion
g3 winning the Queen yeah he went here
check you should be 6 is it's almost the
same yeah now you need to go over here
check and we'll lose the Queen as well
so it's really it's almost like a study
after rookie for this is the absolute
best line and black is just winning
because him at the end it's able to
check first and check this with this
Bishop is able to always win the Queen
by force quite amazing and a really
really great calculation effort by kayak
and he probably had seen it till the end
I mean this is like 80 moves it's not
not bad but not bad so the first ring
for kayaking in this tournament and this
brings both players on minus 1 and while
with only six rounds to play it does not
look like they they get anywhere but ok
kayaking Hattersley has at least a
squadron which is very good for him
obviously playing a drowned center no
witness would have been very frustrating
yeah an interesting end game which I
couldn't really um to to a complete
conclusion also due to time restraints
for the video and for the analysis part
of it um it's also interesting for pro
player service game of flank openings to
notes with less new ideally in with the
quickie form a very good defensive
effort first bike I can you set up the
good defense and then managed to take
over the initiative with good play with
our form probably there's still a draw
in there somewhere for white but it was
tricky to do with limited time
alright thanks for watching